are you in fact vegan no I'm like 95%
vegetarian and what does that mean it
means you're vegetarian most of the year
and then you go to in-n-out burger and
just shove it shove it in every hole of
your body yes but not my mouth and
that's what I think boring it's boring
and also if you see the factory farms
you would not want to eat it no uh no
I'm mostly vegetarian I get my family's
vegetarian we have vegan Thanksgiving
although my family calls it thanks
living what yes what's thanks living
it's just one letter difference but it's
it's um no I know that Thank You
resolved congratulatory exactly yeah no
no it's like we we we buy turkeys we
save turkeys we put the pictures of the
turkeys on the table you buy live
turkeys yes we and then we kind of buy
them in theory you know we save them and
then we put the pictures on the table
like you saved Mabel you saved Todd and
then and then my sister proceeds to read
for about an hour about what it's like
to be a turkey in a cage before
slaughter and then what do you eat tofu
okay now this is an important question
because I know some vegans and they do
this thing we're on Thanksgiving they
eat their tofu molded into the shape of
a turkey right it enrages me do you do
that no no that's silly
it enrages me because it's like don't
eat the turkey or don't eat the turkey
but why do you then put it in the shape
of the right animal that you saved right
special horror but you want the
facsimile of the horse yeah pretend
you're butchering the animals exactly
that's right Wow it's cold thanks living
yes every year it's called thanks live
okay yeah these never invite me to that